Disney films have always been rich territory
for conspiracy theorists. Ranging in legitimacy
from baseless accusations to full-on proof,
fans and critics love to discuss their new
findings with every new release. Talk of subliminal
messaging continues to sweep the internet,
ruffling the feathers of anxious parents everywhere.
Some are right in your face, others need some
freeze framing to find… You might have seen
our other video entitled 10 Inappropriate
Scenes In Disney Films where we covered a
similar topic, but if you haven’t, stick
around until the end for a link to it! Here
is more of Screen Rant’s Dirty Disney: 10
Inappropriate Images in Disney Films.
The Rescuers
While on assignment in New York City, Bernard
and Bianca scour the city for clues. The two
travel by albatross as they soar through the
maze of NYC high-rise buildings. However,
some more astute viewers noticed something
a little extra in the background. In one of
the apartment windows, a topless woman faces
the audience. When played at normal speed,
it’s almost impossible to see. But if you
slow it down, she’s clearly visible.Disney
issued a recall of the home videos in 1999,
but by that time, most of the tapes were probably
worn out in that spot anyway.
The Hunchback of Notre Dame
After being locked in the bell tower by Frollo
his whole life, Quasimodo has a very personal
stake in his demise. Life isn’t all bad
for Quasimodo, though. His friend Esméralda
is a smart, beautiful gypsy who doesn’t
take crap from anyone. And she proves herself
to be a good friend, too. One of her scenes
made some parents take notice though. While
performing a dance in the flames, some argue
that her body is unnecessarily top-heavy.
While others contend that her dress becomes
a little too invisible, and leaves nothing
to the imagination.
The Lion King
The tale of Simba’s life from cub to king
is sure to tug on viewers heart-strings. But
there’s one noteworthy scene that makes
some people do a double-take. As Simba lays
down on a cliff’s edge, he stirs up a cloud
of dust that dissipates in the air. Where
most saw dust drifting into the night sky,
some hyper-vigilant parents claim that Disney’s
animators had a more sinister motive. If you
look closely, you can almost make out a naughty
word hovering in the sky. When they say love
is written in the stars, we don’t think
this is what they meant. This was at the center
of a controversy in the 90’s and has never
been confirmed by Disney, other people say
it says SFX as in Special Effects… we’ll
let you decide if it’s real or not!
Tarzan
First impressions are important, and frankly,
the titular character from Tarzan makes a
bad one. Raised under the watchful eye of
a gorilla named Kala, he has some interesting
social quirks that come out when in the company
of other humans.When he and Jane meet for
the first time, he crosses the line in more
ways than one. Tarzan awkwardly fondles her
foot, peeks up her skirt, and buries his face
in Jane’s chest. What’s worse, she’s
clearly uncomfortable. His intentions may
be pure, but the whole exchange is kind of
creepy.
The Little Mermaid
Given the meticulous nature of animation,
it’s pretty amazing that some of these other
scenes made it through dozens of rounds of
editing. But this image from the 1989 Disney
classic was found in the film’s cover art.
Just like an optical illusion, some people
see it right away, whereas others need a little
more time to figure out what’s… UP with
Triton’s castle. Apparently, the artist
completed the picture at 4 in the morning,
and didn't even notice the resemblance until
a friend mentioned the controversy months
later.
Toy Story
A benefit of using toys for characters is
that storytellers and animators can push the
envelope a little farther, and probably get
away with it too. In fact, there’s a whole
character built on a mature play on words.
The Hooker is a mash-up of sexy lady legs,
and a hook mechanism hanging off a long arm.
Toy Story 2 has it’s share of innuendo,
and shows Buzz Lightyear’s wings springing
to attention after Jesse, the new girl in
town, executes an impressive feat of acrobatics.
Cinderella
Cinderella wouldn’t have gotten her happy
ending if it wasn't for her backup: a fairy
godmother, some birds, and a few mice were
her keys to salvation. Occasionally, the mice
have to do some lousy tasks in the name of
friendship, including threading beads onto
Gus’ tail. But as soon as one fan paused
the image at just the right moment, one of
the funniest, most adult images ever to appear
in a Disney movie was captured forever.
A Goofy Movie
Toy Story isn't the only franchise incorporating
visual puns into it’s repertoire, A Goofy
Movie gets in on the fun as well. At one point
during the fishing trip, the fellas catch
Bigfoot. Luckily for them, his rage fades
and he quickly becomes distracted by some
knick-knacks in a box. He emerges from the
rubble with underwear covering his head, only
part of his face visible. He holds open a
gap in the briefs and peers out, while adults
are chuckling about the literal one-eyed monster
being depicted on screen.
Bambi
While exploring the snowy woods one day, Bambi
and Thumper take to the ice. Swirling and
skating, the rabbit is clearly having a better
time than Bambi, who can barely stay upright.
Like any good friend would, little Thumper
helps get his friend back on his feet. More
than once, we see him move around behind Bambi
and start by lifting his back end off the
ice, his legs following after. The positioning
is a little unsavory in certain frames. If
you watch with a skeptical eye, we’re confident
you’ll understand what we mean. We get that
it’s not obvious to animate such an action,
but we have to ask ourselves “why is Bambi
in THAT position and not another?!” That’s
why you should never pause a Disney movie…
Cars 2
Champion race car Lightning McQueen is on
a hot streak and headed to the World Grand
Prix with his partner in crime, Mater. Accidentally
embroiled in an undercover plot, Mater meets
some real nasty old guys. Referred to as “lemons”
the old, broken-down cars get together for
a party, and the lemon-themed decor has conspiracy
theorists drawing some pretty graphic parallels
- since a "lemon party" is also the term for
a... slippery fetish… Do yourself a favor
and DON’T Google that!
So, what do you think of our list? Did we
miss any inappropriate images from Disney
movies? Tell us about them in the comments
below, and don’t forget to subscribe to
our YouTube channel for more videos like this
one, including our first instalment of Dirty
Disney by clicking on the link at the top
right! Thanks!